a new milestone in the fight against
covet 19 the fda gave the final approval
for pfizer's covid vaccine the vaccine
is now fully approved for people ages 16
and older pfizer's covid19 vaccine the
first one to be fully approved by
federal regulators fda officials hope
the approval lifts public confidence in
the vaccine among the unvaccinated
and the approval is what some people say
they were waiting for joe moeller is
live at the stan fulton building where a
covid testing and vaccine clinic is
underway to tell us how this approval
could increase the lines there and other
places as well joe
o'brien since the vaccine came out many
people have been on the fence about
getting this until the fda did that full
approval like we heard this morning now
with this announcement some medical
experts hope more people will head out
to clinics just like this and then we
can get more people to start getting
fully vaccinated
at first i didn't think it was safe with
full approval more people are lining up
to get their shot since they approved it
now i know it's safe
and i'd rather get it and not get it
hours after the fda approved the kobe 19
pfizer vaccine a pop-up clinic at the
rafael riviera community center in east
las vegas was getting busy it helps
because there's a lot of people that are
scared to get the vaccine this is the
first coven 19 vaccine to get full
approval up until now it was on the
market with an emergency use
authorization but in terms of approval
this this is the final step vaccine
expert doctor jonathan baktari from e-7
health says there is no higher approval
the vaccine can get this is now the
world's largest
study before an approval under the
emergency use authorization millions
received the vaccine he says this makes
it one of the most studied vaccines
there's been no vaccine ever approved in
the united states ever that had not only
the 40 some odd thousand the pfizers
giving the fda but we're also giving
the fda the 92 million people that got
the vaccine as part of their analysis
clinics like the one at the raphael
riviera community center will continue
to pop up it's a trust factor peter
guzman from the latino chamber of
commerce says this may push more people
to get to clinics like this i think it
will give people more confidence and
that's kind of what we've been waiting
for those people that are you know a
little bit nervous
i think now you know with the fda
approval it'll certainly get them over
the hump of being nervous and scared
now back out here live the johnson and
johnson and moderna vaccines are still
being studied but approval is expected
for those as well now you're taking a
look at a line of vehicles here for the
testing and vaccination clinic going on
here this goes on until about 10 30 this
evening and will reopen tomorrow at 5 30
but cars do start lining up around 4
o'clock reporting live at unlv joe
mullen 8 news now